- [Vaishnavi] Oh, it's one o'clock.
Hey everyone, I hope you're having
a great time at re:Invent.
So before we get started,
quick show of hands,
how many of you hate managing passwords,
access keys, long term
credentials in general?
Alright, that's pretty much
everybody in the audience here
so we have some great news for you.
A new launch.
My name is Ram Maharajapuram.
I am a senior software development manager
and head of engineering
for security token service.
And with me here today is Vaishnavi Merugu
a senior product manager on the team.
And we are here to talk to
you about our latest launch
that makes it easy for you
to connect your workloads
to external services.
Oftentimes builders have to trade off
between security and ease of use.
And with this new solution,
you no longer have to face that dilemma.
You now have a native way
to exchange your AWS credentials
and use them to connect
to any third party services.
So this could be other
cloud service providers,
it could be on-prem workloads,
it could be SaaS providers.
So cloud service providers like Azure GCP,
SaaS providers such as
Databricks, Snowflake,
and you could do this natively
using the AWS credentials
that are already available
to you for any role,
any IAM user.
These credentials more often
are actually delivered natively
to the compute that you're
using, AWS Lambda, EC2,
Amazon EKS, you name it.
We have a secure way for you
to connect those workloads
to these external services.
And we do this using standards
aligned JSON web tokens
or JWTs for shot.
And with this you no longer
have to use complex workarounds
and you certainly do not have to manage
any long-term credentials.
So I'm actually gonna do a
quick live demo of this feature.
What I'm going to be doing
is I'm going to be
connecting my EC2 instance
to Azure and make calls to Azure APIs
without ever having to
create an Azure access key,
like a long-term credential
or setting up a password.
So what I have here is an EC2 instance.
So you can see here that it is live
and I'm gonna kick this
off by running a script
that I've prepared for you.
We're gonna go through seven steps.
The first of these is
to basically just check
what credentials I have.
I ran the command aws
sts get caller identity.
It's basically the who am I
command that we have on AWS.
And what you see here
is I have credentials
that belong to an EC2 instance role.
So when you spin up an EC2 instance,
we actually have short term
credentials session tokens
that are delivered for you.
These are valid only for a few hours
and these credentials can be
scoped down however you want.
And I'm going to be
using these credentials
for federating out into Azure.
So in order for you to use this feature,
you would first have to go ahead
and enable the outbound
identity federation feature.
I already have this feature
enabled on my account,
so I'm just using the GET
version of this command
aws iam get outbound web
identity federation info.
And what I get here is a
JSON with two elements.
The first element is an issue identifier.
So when you enable this feature,
we create a set of asymmetric
keys for your account.
We also create a unique
identifier for your account
and we host the public
keys corresponding to it
on this URL
and your relying party
can then call this URL
and get those keys.
We'll get to that in a
bit more detail later.
And it also says that JWT
vending enabled is true.
That's exciting.
So let's actually go look at
what that JWT actually looks like.
So I now ran the command aws
sts get web identity token.
The response that I got
has two elements in it,
a web identity token and
an expiration timestamp.
I truncated the token
just so that we don't,
it's easier for us to
kind of talk through it.
But essentially this token
has three parts to it.
There is a header that's
shown in green color here.
There is a payload and
there is a signature
associated with that token.
There's also an expiration timestamp.
The expiration here by
default is five minutes.
You could also extend that
beyond five minutes up to an hour
if you would like to do so
by just passing an API parameter to this.
And you can also see that I
passed an audience parameter
into this call
because we are gonna be
using this token to exchange
with Azure and we also have
a signing algorithm here.
I chose RS256 but there are other options
available for you as well.
So let's just actually look
into what is inside this token.
So all I did is I did a base64 D code
on this token and ran it
through a JSON parser.
So what you see here is a subject,
on the subject here is nothing,
it's basically the same
as my EC2 instance role
that we used in order to get this JWT.
You can also see a bunch
of other standard claims
including the issuer that
we talked about earlier,
an expiration timestamp
and if issuer at timestamp and so on.
And there is also a bunch
of interesting credentials
specific or workload specific
claims that we have namespace
to sts dotamazonaws.com.
This includes things like
properties of your EC2 instance,
it includes information about
your org if you have one.
It also includes things like the tags
that you actually have on the role
and if you have session tags and so on
those will also appear here.
There's an interesting kind
of off-label use case here.
Use this feature to go introspect
your authorization context
and get additional information
on like what tags you have
and so on if you are kind of
going through troubleshooting
and what have you.
So here's the moment of truth,
what I did is I took that credential
and I exchanged this to
an Azure access token.
So in order to do that,
I posted that token
to the Azure Token Exchange endpoint.
I passed the grant type
as client credentials.
I said that the assertion
type is JWT bearer
and I got essentially a token back.
Now what I can do is then use these tokens
to go call other Azure APIs.
And what you see here is
that I'm using this token
to call the graph API for an application
that I've already set up.
And the API that I'm calling
is federated identity credentials.
Interestingly, this is
all the setup that I had
to do on Azure in order
to connect my application.
So I gave Azure the subject,
which is the EC2 instance role
I gave Azure the if you
are URL, the unique URL
for my account that we
talked about earlier.
And the audience
and I created a federated
credential using that
and that was enough for me
to securely connect to AWS.
Now we spoke about those issuer URLs.
So you may be wondering
how did Azure actually validate the token
that we gave to it.
So what we publish is
a couple of well-known
endpoints on that issuer URL.
The first is called the well-known
Open ID configuration endpoint.
This basically tells you what
kind of claims we support,
what kind of token algorithms we support,
and a URL for the JSON web key set.
This is where our public
keys are actually hosted.
And then what you see
here is I'm also curling
the JSON web key document.
And you see here that the
public keys corresponding
to the RFA algorithm type
and an ECDSA algorithm type are available.
So what Azure did behind the scenes
is they went to the configured point,
they then figured out what
the the JWKS endpoint was
and they then subsequently
call that endpoint
to get the public keys
and validate my token.
Now if you're using this
for your own workloads,
we've made it super easy for you.
You can pick any library
that understands parses
JOSN web tokens and those
libraries would be able
to natively do do this for you.
We have some example
libraries on our documentation
and to tell you more about the claims
and additional fine-grain controls
that we have I'll invite
Vaishnavi on stage.
- Thank you Ram.
So now that we've all seen an
exciting demo of this feature,
let's talk about what
are the primary benefits
of using this feature.
The first one's obvious, right?
This is enhanced security
because you're now eliminating
long-term credentials
from your environment.
So quick interesting fact,
two thirds of the cases
that come to the customer
incident response team
are due to an initial access
by an unintended actor using
valid long-term credentials.
So take advantage of this feature
and replace your long-term credentials
with short-lived JSON web
tokens for secure access
to external services.
The second one is reduced
operational complexity.
You no longer have to
manage these long-term creds
or rotate them frequently.
If you were using pre-signed URLs
and complex authentication
flows to integrate
with these external services,
you can replace all of that
with a simple few lines of code.
A simple API call to get
web identity token API
and get a JWT for authentication
with external services.
Third is the interoperability.
So this feature was
designed to be interoperable
with many of your cloud service
providers, SaaS providers,
and even used for authentication
between your own
applications hosted on cloud
or on premises.
Now let's actually do a
quick recap of the claims
that you just saw in the demo.
So the claims can be broadly
categorized into two.
The first one is your standard YDC claims.
So these are again designed
to be interoperable.
So we have the standard
subject claim which identifies
the role or the user
or the IAM principle
that's being federated
to the external service.
We have the audience of the token,
we have the expiration
time, a unique identifier
for this JWT and the issuer URL.
Then we have a set of custom claims
that AWS puts in the token on your behalf.
All of these claims are names spaced under
sts.amazonaws.com and this
includes identity context,
session context, compute context,
and even your principle tags, request tags
that you can add to the token.
Let's actually pay special
attention to the issuer URL here.
So when we were building this feature,
we thought what would be a
good way to deliver a secure
by design experience for customers?
And we decided to go with a
issuer URL that's specific
to your AWS account to
guarantee tenant isolation.
So now let's look at the
custom claims within the token.
The AWS account ID is
included in the token.
This helps the downstream service validate
that the token is coming from
the account that you trust.
We also include the source region,
which is the AWS region from which
the token generation request was made.
If your AWS account is
part of an organization,
we include the organization ID
and the OU path in the token as well.
Then we have principle tags.
So if your IAM principle,
like your role or your user
has tags attached to them,
those tags show up under
the principle tags.
And if your assumed role
session has session tags
attached to them, the
session tags also show up
in the principle tag section.
Both of these can be used
for fine grained authorization
in the downstream service.
Then we include some context
that's particular to your compute.
So in Ram's example, you may have seen
that there were some claims
pertaining to the EC2 instance.
So for example, if it
was a Lambda function
that's actually federating its identity,
you would see lambda function
specific claims in the token.
And if the identity originally federated
from an external provider,
we also include the federated provider on.
And there are a lot of other
claims that are very specific
to your session context
and your compute context.
You can go through the full
list on our documentation.
Now, if you wanted to add
your own claims to the token,
you could do that by
passing the tags parameter
to the API call and specify
the key value pairs.
All of these would show up
under the request tag section
in the token,
and you can use these again
for fine-grained authorization
in the external service.
Now let's talk about how
you can control access
to this feature for your IAM principles.
So the permission to keep in mind here
is the STS get web identity token.
Any IAM principle who has this permission
in their policies will be able to generate
JSON web tokens for authentication
with external services.
So you can use this permission
in any and all relevant policy types
like your SCPs, RCPs identity
based policies, VPC policies.
We are also introducing
three new condition keys
as part of this feature.
The first one is the
identity token audience.
Using this condition key,
you can restrict the list
of audiences and ensure
that your I am principles
only generate tokens
for these audiences.
And if they try to generate a token
for any other audience,
the request will fail.
We also have the STS duration seconds.
So this condition key can be used
to enforce maximum token lifetimes.
So tokens are valid for
five minutes by default,
but the token lifetime can range
anywhere between 60 seconds
to one hour and you can set maximum
so token lifetimes that
suit your operational needs
and your security requirements.
Finally, we have the
STS signing algorithm.
So we currently support
two signing algorithms,
ES384 and RS256.
So you can use this condition key
to specify the signing algorithm
to be used to sign the token.
Now let's talk about a few best practices.
Before that, let me tell
you that this feature
is available in all
AWS commercial regions,
GovCloud regions, and
China regions at launch.
And this feature is available
at no additional cost to customers.
So like I mentioned before,
the primary goal of building this feature
is to eliminate long-term
credentials from your environment.
So please replace all your API keys,
your passwords with
short-term, short-lived JWTs
and make them as short as possible
to prevent unintended access.
Look at the authorization
context in your token
after you validate the signature.
So ensure that the tokens
actually issued by AWS
and it's valid before you look
at the authorization context.
Also look at the custom
claims in the token
that AWS populates whenever possible
to do more fine-grained access control
in the downstream service.
Make sure you don't log these tokens.
You can request for a fresh
token anytime you need.
And also make sure you send
these requests over TLS.
You can refer to these QR
codes for more resources.
The first one is our blog post,
which talks about a walkthrough
of how to use this feature.
And for an in-depth guide
you can look at our documentation as well.
So thank you so much for joining us today.
- Alright, and please do
take the session survey
once it pops up on the app.
Thank you very much once again.